Rassismus in der Schweiz
war das Thema unserer Reportage.
"Der Sommer,
in dem ich 'Schwarz' wurde."
Ein Film über Angélique Beldner,
die erste schwarze News-Moderatorin
vom SRF.
Es gab sehr viele Kommentare
und Rückmeldungen auf den Film.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank auch
für die angeregten Diskussionen
in der Kommentarspalte
und abseits von YouTube.
Einige Rückmeldungen löschten wir,
weil sie nicht
unserer Netiquette entsprechen.
D.h., sie waren entweder rassistisch
oder anderweitig beleidigend.
Jetzt zu den Fragen.
In den nächsten Minuten versuchen
wir, einige davon zu beantworten.
Angélique, zum Einstieg:
Du hattest grosse Hemmungen,
diesen Film zu machen.
Es kostete dich viel Überwindung,
so viel Persönliches preiszugeben
und dir klarzumachen, was
dieser Sommer bei dir bewirkt hat.
Der Film
ist vor einigen Tagen erschienen.
Wie geht es dir?
Mir geht es sehr, sehr gut.
Während wir den Film drehten,
fragte ich mich immer wieder:
Wird das eigentlich ankommen?
Das, was ich sagen möchte.
Wird man das verstehen?
Kann man es überhaupt verstehen?
Denn: Vor diesem Sommer
habe ich ja noch nie
mit jemandem darüber gesprochen.
Und jetzt spreche ich
vor der Kamera darüber.
Ich bekam sehr viele wunderschöne
Rückmeldungen, vielen Dank.
Und das tut gut, das bestärkt mich.
Ich habe das Gefühl: Ja, was ich
sagen wollte, ist angekommen.
Man versteht das -
und vielen geht es auch so.
Sie erleben das auch,
in der einen oder anderen Form.
Ich nehme nun eine Frage auf:
Warum dauerte es 44 Jahre,
bis du dich überhaupt ...
... "dem gestellt hast"
ist eine wertende Aussage.
Aber warum dauerte es 44 Jahre,
bis dir klar wurde,
dass da etwas ist, das du dein Leben
lang unterdrückt hast.
Warum ich 44 Jahre geschwiegen habe,
sozusagen.
Weil es für mich einfach
der einfachere Weg war.
Wenn ich das mal angestossen hatte,
merkte ich,
dass es beim Gegenüber nicht ankommt.
Da ist es einfacher zu schweigen,
es sein zu lassen
und sich irgendeinen Weg
durch all das zu bahnen.
Damit es funktioniert.
Jemand schreibt z.B.,
er habe selbst ein weisses
und ein schwarzes Elternteil.
Und er empfinde es
nicht als Beleidigung,
wenn man ihn
Latte Macchiato oder so nennt.
Das ist in Ordnung,
wenn ihn das nicht stört.
Ich finde es wichtig, dass jene
Menschen ernst genommen werden,
die sagen: "Es macht mir etwas aus."
- Nämlich?
Es tut mir weh, es trifft mich.
Ich empfinde das als abwertend.
Wenn ich z.B.
in meinem geschäftlichen Umfeld
mit jemandem diskutiere und ich
diese Person auf Augenhöhe wahrnehme,
und sie plötzlich
auf ein äusserliches Merkmal eingeht,
und in einem Nebensatz sagt: "Frauen
wie du, so Latte Macchiato" ...
Dann habe ich in diesem Moment das
Gefühl, nicht auf Augenhöhe zu sein.
Ich bin eine Stufe runtergefallen.
Und das anzusprechen,
ist nicht einfach.
Jemandem plausibel zu erklären,
was es ist,
das mich in diesem Moment trifft,
ist nicht einfach.
Jemand fragte, was der Unterschied
zwischen Rassismus, Sexismus
und Diskriminierung sei, er gehe
davon aus, dass du alles erlebt hast.
Spielt es für dich eine Rolle,
gibt es Unterschiede?
Es ist nicht das Gleiche,
aber man sollte nicht
das eine gegen das andere ausspielen.
Das eine
ist nicht schlimmer als das andere.
Und oft liegt es nahe beieinander.
Ich kann vielleicht
eine Anekdote erzählen.
Als ich vor vielen Jahren
bei einem Radio arbeitete,
planten wir eine Werbekampagne.
Bei mir war der Werbespruch
"Zum Frühstück heisse Schokolade".
Also unter deinem Foto?
Ein Foto von mir und darunter
"zum Frühstück heisse Schokolade".
Ich habe mich dort nicht
so richtig getraut, mich zu wehren.
Ich sagte zwar,
dass ich das nicht wollte.
Aber mein damaliger Chef meinte,
man müsse auch
über sich selbst lachen können.
Und ich bin verstummt.
Das ganze Team wehrte sich für mich,
und die Kampagne kam nicht zustande.
Es gab weitere solcher Sprüche,
ich war nicht die einzige.
Bei mir war es rassistisch
und sexistisch.
Bei anderen Frauen war es sexistisch.
Es ist schwierig,
z.T. liegt es nahe beieinander.
Warum ist es so schlimm, jemanden
zu fragen, woher man kommt?
Wie gross ist der Spielraum?
Wann würdest du das fragen?
Nein, das finde ich
wirklich ganz wichtig.
Wenn man sich
für einen Menschen interessiert,
dann liegen sehr viele Fragen drin.
Es ist keine indiskrete Frage.
Aber es ist eine persönliche Frage.
Wenn ich persönlich
jemandem erklären möchte,
woher ich ursprünglich stamme,
folgt eine extrem lange Geschichte,
die dazugehört.
Denn ohne die komplette Geschichte
kann ich die Frage nicht beantworten.
Sie passt nicht in einen Satz.
Darum geht es.
Und ...
Ich erlebte und erlebe es oft,
dass man sich begrüsst,
sich mit Namen vorstellt und dann
wird gefragt, woher man kommt.
Bei dir ist das so?
- Das passiert mir sehr oft.
Und bei dieser Frage auf diesem Level
lautet die Antwort immer: "Aus Bern".
Hier eine Kritik von Carole.
Sie hätte eine Triggerwarnung
bei diesem Online-Beitrag erwartet,
die darauf aufmerksam macht,
dass problematische Begriffe
und Bilder zu sehen
und zu hören sind.
Wir haben darüber diskutiert
und entschieden uns
gegen eine Triggerwarnung.
In der Szene, die du v.a. ansprichst,
die Stammtischrunde,
in der das N-Wort mehrfach benutzt
wird, ist das Wort eingebettet.
Darum entschieden wir uns dagegen.
Aber man hätte auch tatsächlich
eine machen können.
Carole geht noch weiter.
Das betrifft dich, Angélique.
Es geht um die Szene, in der ein
Mann kam und dich während Minuten -
wir haben es gekürzt im Film -
mit irgendwelchen Informationen
zugetextet hat.
Sie findet,
da hätten wir eingreifen sollen.
Wir taten das nicht.
Du hast die Szene bzw. das Gespräch
selbst beendet.
Das Ende des Gesprächs
sieht man im Film.
Hätten wir eingreifen sollen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich danke Carole für diese Frage.
Weil ich dadurch selbst beginne,
darüber nachzudenken.
Hätte man eingreifen sollen?
Ich bin es nicht gewohnt, dass man
eingreift in solchen Situationen.
Ich wurde ein Leben lang alleine
gelassen mit solchen Dingen.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es anders gewesen wäre,
wenn du oder der Kameramann
dort eingegriffen hättet.
Aber ich muss sagen: Ich fühlte mich
dort nicht ganz so schlimm,
weil ihr da wart.
Alleine eure Anwesenheit
hat mir irgendwie geholfen.
Auch, weil mir dann bewusst war:
Jetzt kann ich das mal beweisen.
Denn: Wenn ich so etwas erlebe -
das glaubt mir ja niemand.
Man glaubt es einfach nicht.
Und da passierte es,
zwei schauten zu.
Und irgendwann wurde mir klar:
Die Kamera läuft auch noch.
In diesem speziellen Fall
war das gar nicht so schlecht.
Vielleicht noch kurz zur Situation
aus unserer Sicht.
Es war extrem unangenehm.
Und gleichzeitig fragte ich mich,
warum du ihm nicht einfach sagst:
"Gehen Sie bitte."
Das fragte ich mich wirklich,
warum du nicht ...
Man kann es ja anständig sagen.
Warum hast du ihn nicht abgewiesen?
Das hatte ja nichts mit uns zu tun,
oder?
Für mich war es verrückt,
als ich selbst das Bildmaterial sah.
Ich bin über mich selbst erschrocken.
Wie freundlich ich
diesen Mann anlächle.
Da merkte ich ganz fest, wie meine
eigenen Mechanismen funktionieren.
Ich finde es selbst erschreckend.
Es gibt noch eine Frage,
die mehrmals gestellt wurde.
Warum du dich als schwarz
bezeichnest?
Du bezeichnest dich ja nicht nur
als schwarz, oder? - Nein.
Aber im Film
sprechen wir von schwarz.
Du seist ja halb-halb,
also halb weiss, halb schwarz.
Ob man da nicht
Mischling sagen könnte -
oder was du wirklich bist,
nämlich nicht nur schwarz.
Diese Abstufung im Schwarz-Sein,
das wurde hier angesprochen.
Für mich persönlich ist es bestimmt
anders als für viele andere.
Bis zu diesem Sommer
war es mir immer wichtig, zu sagen,
dass ich nicht einfach schwarz bin,
sondern schwarz und weiss.
Dass ich etwas dazwischen bin.
Den richtigen Begriff
habe ich nie gefunden.
Und in diesem Sommer
begann sich das zu ändern,
und ich sagte: "Ich bin schwarz".
Nicht auf die reine Hautfarbe
bezogen,
sondern auf die Identifizierung
des Ganzen -
was auch immer das ist.
Ich finde die Frage nach dem
richtigen Begriff sehr schwierig.
Ich diskutiere so oft
mit schwarzen Menschen.
Die einen empfinden
farbig als falsch,
die anderen Mischling, schwarz
oder coloured.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Im englischsprachigen Raum
hat man sich auf PoC geeinigt.
In der Schweiz
hört man das auch immer mehr.
Aber es ist immer noch
ein englischer Begriff.
Ich fände es schön,
einen deutschen Begriff zu haben,
auf den man sich einigen könnte.
Aber momentan
bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig,
als den Menschen zuzuhören, was sie
für sich als richtig empfinden.
Wir gehen weiter.
Till fragt,
ob man intervenieren soll,
wenn man hört, dass jemand etwas
Rassistisches zu jemandem sagt.
Soll man dann einschreiten?
Wie soll man sich verhalten?
Ja, unbedingt, sehr, sehr gern.
Denn ich muss sagen:
Es ist viel schwieriger,
für sich selbst hinzustehen
und sich zu wehren,
als für eine andere Person.
Und ich glaube,
oft wird es ernster genommen,
wenn es andere auch noch sagen.
Und nicht nur die Betroffenen selbst.
Unbedingt hinstehen und etwas sagen.
Ich kann mich nur bedanken -
v.a. bei Angélique Beldner.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
unfassbar viel gelernt zu haben.
Es war eindrücklich,
diesen Film zu machen
und so nahe
in ein Familiengefüge zu sehen.
Und auch diese Ehrlichkeit
zu erleben.
Das ist wohl der Schlüssel,
um Verständnis zu schaffen:
möglichst ehrlich und ungeschönt
zu erzählen, wie es wirklich ist.
Wenn ihr immer noch Fragen habt,
stellt sie doch in den Kommentaren.
Wir versuchen nach wie vor,
sie zu beantworten.